[Music]
today we have a really great treat
professor Josie and we'll spend vinkle
if I said that right I think it's just a
great name who did her undergraduate at
Utrecht and her graduate work there also
got her PhD and then worked at the
Whitehead Institute up and at MIT and
then we've been fortunate to have her as
a new faculty member for the last of
five six years or something four years
four years right and she does some
really interesting work in in in RNA
biology and she's going to tell us a
little bit about some of the things that
are that are that are related and how
she became a scientist so Jamie and
whelping welcoming professor Wilson
Nikhil so thank you for the nice
introduction I'm going to start out by
thanking or asking for a big round
applause for all the volunteers who've
helped set up all these demos and for
professor zoom for organizing all of
this I hope you've enjoyed the most I
want to take a moment to thank them all
for that
so my name is Yasiin and i am a
professor in biology and one of the
biology departments here and that means
that I teach the students here and that
I also have a group of people that we
run a lap with so we have a group of
people together we do research with and
today I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about what that research is that we're
doing and why we're doing this so well
as I said I'm a biologist and so that
means the study of living things and the
way we study biology is is in a large
part by observing so we look at biology
as it happens in real life we look at it
observe it in in the wild we also bring
it into the lab and use microscopes to
look at the organisms and we study and
then we do experiments and do analysis
and try to understand how things
actually work and to tell you a little
bit about how I got into this as
professor zoom mentioned I am originally
not from the US I'm originally from
Netherlands this is a tiny country in
Europe over there
I think it's smaller than Connecticut if
it it's definitely not that much larger
you may have heard of it because of its
tulips it's a it exports a lot of tulips
and it has these beautiful old cities
with canals and released steep houses
and lots and lots and lots of bikes and
so I grew up there in its 8080 this is
me when I was about 7 years old with my
brother and sister and cousins and we
lived in a in a smaller city in the in
the Netherlands and it was a little
parks around and I'd say we were always
interested in anything that lived around
us we would always drag things in that
we felt needed help so here we found a
nest of of eggs and a bird that was was
a head or an untucked that was hatching
these eggs and so every day we'd feed
the bird and then check whether the eggs
were still there and how it was going
was progressing also any other animal so
if there are stray cats around we would
always manage to direct them home and
help grow them up many times we had many
different types of animals that didn't
necessarily go well together like birds
that fell out of the nest together with
the cats together with a rabbit that
fell in a ditch and try to old nurse
them back
so in some way I'm always interested in
in the things that we're living around
me but that doesn't necessarily mean
that I always knew I wanted to be a
biologist in fact when I was in school I
enjoyed a lot of the science subjects I
really like math I really enjoyed
physics and I really enjoyed chemistry
and i photolyse things were very
beautiful there were systems where you
can learn to understand learn to do
calculations and if they are very neat
in a way that if you if you know how to
do a calculator you can solve an
equation if you know how forces work you
can understand how a spring can move
back and forth and if you understand a
bit about chemistry you can understand
how molecules can come together and what
kind of reactions they would do and to
me actually at that time biology was a
little bit fuzzy it seemed that it was
very difficult to understand and it took
me all the way until the end of high
school actually to realize that the
reason biology of fuzzy is because it's
very complicated and that it takes all
these things that we learn in math all
these principles from math and from
physics and chemistry that are all true
but they're all combined in biology they
all work together and together to create
these things that are very meaningful to
us the things that we like to eat the
creatures that we like to call our
friends and and actually make up the
complex ecosystems around us that are
both very important to us but also bone
shape the world as we know it and so
that actually that thing about biology
that in some way was the most
complicated or the most difficult to me
is actually what Indians had the most
value to me of how complex these things
are that are that are together and how
delicate it actually is that this works
and so to emphasize that a little bit
more and to think about how diverse
biology actually is I want to go for a
couple of examples of how wide and vast
that that's that diversity is and how
beautiful some of these things are so
one of the things to think about in
biology is skill so just the size of
things this is a skill that is drawn in
in meters so we are somewhere between 1
and 2 meters typically but there's
animals that are much much larger that
like wills can be tens and tens of
meters long on the other hand we know of
many organisms that are smaller we know
if we go to the beach and we look at
shells that we find that are typically
about a centimeter or so so centimeter
is if you look at your index finger you
take that little bit from the last joint
to your into the end of your finger
that's about a centimeter but there's
many things that are much much smaller
so if you would divide that into ten
little pieces then you get to a
millimeter lots of animals are around
outside if you even divide that a
thousand times more into tiny little
pieces you get to decide of microbes so
really really small things can be alive
and only around really really big things
are there in biology as well take
another example how fast can things go
there's a huge variety so cheetahs that
can go 75 miles per hour which is as
fast as your car drives on the highway
and there they have an enormous amount
of muscle that they use to to be able to
achieve that on the other hand sloths
although they look very cute they're
very very slow and they can they have
used their energy in a very different
way so they optimized to well be very
efficient with their energy but and are
very slow in their movements and there's
animals like for example hummingbirds
that can flap their wings 70 times per
second just to imagine is one 270 times
in every beat
just give it a well you can give it a
try we won't be able to do it
other animals for example a recent story
was about his blind cave salamander it
actually sits still for seven years so
it doesn't move very well barely moves
at all huge variety again also in how
long things can live so for example
mayflies we know live only for a day but
tortoises can live for over well over a
hundred years and even apart from that
when we look at where biology looks it
can also create some of the prettiest
colors and prettiest shapes that we can
imagine some examples are here some of
the prettiest bird swim feathers that
make all these beautiful colors
structures that animals can make for
example some that halves
taking features that they can use to get
praise in or very thin tentacles with
stinging cells that they can use it at
little harpoons to shoot and Catchings
beautiful structures with the check and
filter water beautiful fins all these
very complicated structures and
beautiful colors are there for our
biology
so if biology is so diverse and if it
can look in so many different takes so
many different shapes how can we even
think that we might understand any of
this use if everything is so completely
different where would we even start and
so the answer to that is actually just
just like you would do with a giant
jigsaw puzzle we just do it one piece at
a time
you find one little bit that you can
figure out and that's where you start
and then from there we try to build and
that's actually exactly what we did in
biology and what we the way we have
started to try and understand about how
biology works and but how all this
adversity comes about is by picking a
set of organisms set of systems that we
study and those we call model organisms
and we pick things that actually are all
around us and that we very commonly come
across we picked yeast which is the
organism that we use to make bread and
make beer it has been with us for
thousands of years we know how to grow
it it's been with us forever
fruit flies if you ever have had some
very ripe bananas or apples or basically
any type of fruit you'll know that these
magically come there you don't really
have to do anything to attract them
you'll find them Arab adopts this is
this a wheat that might grow in your
yard and grows all around mice if you've
ever lived in an old house you know that
they'll find you
and these are little worms that live in
the soil everywhere and we later on we
also found a fish that we use as a model
system so these are examples of biology
they're not don't represent all of it
but we picked a couple of places to
start a couple of puzzle pieces to start
with and from that what we found is
something that we call biological
conservation and this is a very
important concept so I'll take a moment
to explain that what we found between
these differ
very different systems is it actually
they work in a very similar way and in a
way that is so similar that it cannot be
a coincidence let me explain it in a
different way how many of you know the
song twinkle twinkle little star all of
you crave so imagine you might have as a
child I've hurt your mother singers to
you you might have heard a teacher in
school singers to you you might have
gone to the playground and heard you're
a father singer to their child and so
one possibility would be that all those
people your mother your teacher the
father in the playground that they all
came up with the same words and the kiss
a melody by themselves and started
singing a song so who you think that
this might be this is a real possibility
so very few sir I would say that
probably nobody thinks that that is what
what happens
does anybody have a theory how could
just have happens do you want yeah
somebody told them exactly
there has been somebody in the past who
came about a song who came up with these
lyrics and we may not know anymore would
it was what this person looked like when
this was this person may not be here
around us anymore but they came up with
this song and they use it and they told
it to some people and they told it to
other people and this is how it spread
and this is exactly how we think about
the similarities in biology some of
these things
that the ordinary nerves are actually
all the principles that these organisms
use are so similar and they use them in
exactly the same way that this is not by
coincidence this is because there was an
organism long long time ago that's not
with us anymore
but was there hundreds of millions of
years ago that use these or these
principles for the first time and we now
they're spread through all the organisms
around us and so this is a this is a
very important concept of what we found
but let me explain to you a little bit
more about how deep that conservation
goes so in the first place all organisms
that we know of all living organisms are
made out of cells and cells are
basically bubbles they're membranes
around
the piece of of space where the reaction
conditions where conditions are very
stable and which make up all these
living organisms and within these cells
there's all kinds of other structures
often surrounded by membranes that help
these units to make energy to make
components and that are important for
the functioning and one of these very
important components is what we call the
nucleus or the core of the cell this is
nucleus it's important because it
contains some of the material that is we
call the DNA so every cell contains a
nucleus and in the nucleus are what we
call chromosomes and the chromosomes are
actually really really really long
strands of DNA they're packed together
in there if you would all put all the
DNA of one of our cells and stretch
stretch it out it would actually be six
feet long so this is really a long
amount of DNA in that it's all packed
it'll just one little nucleus so when we
look at the DNA what it actually is it's
a really long string as I said and it
contains well the string itself is it's
made out of a backbone a sugar backbone
and there's four different types of
beads which are the basis so we have a C
G and a and a t and so it's a really no
string with these four different colors
that can be in any kind of order and
there is millions and millions of these
bases together that make up the sequence
of our DNA so the DNA actually is not
just this one single strand it has a
very good trick to it and that is that
it's double-stranded so some of there's
two strands
that's circle around each other we call
a double helix and there's always two
bases that go together so an a always
wants to go with a T and AC always wants
to go with a G so these two are actually
the same kind of information is in there
twice because if we know that there's an
T here we know there has to be an A in
the other one
and this makes this very stable and
makes that the information is actually
stored in a very
reliable way that even if something
would go wrong if for example bass would
flip out we actually know how to repair
it because we know exactly how to get
that bass back and what bass that should
be what we so gives this information the
fact that this is double-stranded is
actually actively used by the cell
because cells one of the core things
about life is that things have to
multiply have to be able to persist for
a long time and what the cells will do
is that they they will duplicate their
DNA and the way that works is that you
can separate the two strands and now you
know for each of the two strands what it
has to make you know that this one where
the T was going to make an a where the G
was it'll have to make a C and so we can
just go on and make that second strand
and the other strands at which separate
us we can do the exact same thing we can
just make them and now we have two
copies that are completely identical and
this is the way that information is
actually multiplied in an organism this
is used a lot in them in biology every
time a cell duplicates it duplicates its
DNA and so this is a process that we
call the cell cycle so if we start out
with it going cell that has two strands
of DNA two chromosomes in here the first
thing it will do when it wants to
amplify or multiply is that it doesn't
process called DNA replication and so it
duplicates its chromosomes so this is
exactly the process we just looked at of
duplicating the information and then
these cells go through a process where
they align these chromosomes in a way
that they can separate them so that the
information will be split evenly between
the two different different partitions
and then the SOCAN divides and these two
cells that it's dividing into will now
have the exact same information so all
the information is copied and this is at
the core of the development of every
organism actually of every multicellular
organism because as you may know we as
organisms also other animals and other
plants we all originally come from one
cell we all start out as one Excel and
one sperm cell coming together
and that activates some important
processes but this one individual cell
then starts to divide it makes more and
more and more cells that over time start
to fit make structures make different
shapes start to differentiate as we call
it to make different different types of
cells and in eventually make an entire
organism so this means that all
ourselves all the cells in our body are
derived from this one single cell and
they all contain the exact same DNA
molecules the exact same sequences so
what is in this DNA that is so important
why or why are we so why do we want to
keep it around all the time well what it
is is actually lots and lots and lots of
these bases lots and lots and lots of
letters our genome contains 300 billion
of them and so this is this is an
enormous amount of information a whole
bunch of it we don't exactly know what
it is but there are some parts of it
where there is a kind of alert sequence
it's a kind of little sign like now pay
attention and this is what we call a
promoter and this is a start of a gene a
gene is then a piece of the DNA where a
copy can be made and that actually helps
to to make a protein so the DNA by
itself is just the information it
doesn't really do anything but the gene
is the recipe to make a protein and that
makes all the functions in the cell so
what this alert sequence is promoter
does its alert to cell and get a complex
we call an RNA polymerase to make a
little copy that we call RNA and that
copy then is the recipe to make a
protein so the genes are actually the
instructions these are the units that
are very important to a cell and you can
see them as how kind of the recipes so
they are telling the cell what to make
and how to make it and these proteins
then are the structures make up all the
structures in the cell and do all the
things in these cells so not only disss
so this is what we found was one of the
things that is widely
conserve all organisms have cells or
organisms have DNA or organisms make RNA
make proteins and it is in the same way
but it goes deeper than that actually
when we look at these genes at these
instructions it turns out those are also
very widely conserved so there are also
very similar between different organisms
one example for this for example is
actin this is a structure that is in the
cells it's there's green fibers here and
that makes what we call the cytoskeleton
so the skeleton of the cell it makes the
structures it makes this it helps the
tension of the cells these fibers are
actually not one thing every single
fiber is made out of lots of tiny little
units so in that way it's a little bit
like the DNA is lots of little bits and
the accidents a lot of little proteins
that are making them together and this
is what that looks like so these are
these individual proteins every single
yellow one here is an individual protein
and these can come together and can
build a chain and it always grows in the
same direction and so it gets longer and
longer and actually while it's growing
it changes its state a little bit and so
it can also well D polymerize so fall
apart again on the other side and this
is an extremely important thing for the
cell because it allows the cell to build
structures to put out fibers to move
this is an example of a cell like that
that because of the actin is able to put
out feelers and to feel around and to
actually move its entire body over and
this is what happens in our bodies to
der cells that are on the move cells for
example in our in our bloodstream that
have to get out of the bloodstream that
are moving and using these these fibers
to move around so now if we look at this
actin at this protein and look at it in
different different systems we can look
at the actin from a mouse or the actin
from a microbe from one of these really
really tiny micrometers small organisms
and when we look at what their proteins
look like they actually look exactly the
same if we overlay them we can barely
see the different
they make the exact same structure and
I'll only do they look the same they
function the same so they also make
these polymers and they help protrude
these fibers so this is a very important
protein for farol cells it goes even
further than that so I told you about
RNA polymerase that is necessary to make
RNA and to make protein as a RNA
polymerase itself actually is a protein
and so it's very well conserved it is a
gene but one thing you may realize is
that I've skipped over something I've
told you dance all the cells in our body
have the same DNA have the exact same
genes but we know that not all our cells
look exactly the same way and we know
that there's cells for example in our
that our brain cells are neurons are
able to signal they're able to guide
electrical pulses and to they have
really long connections so that we can
feel something that's happening in our
toe and signal that truth to the brain
we also know that for example the
muscles in our in our stomach can
contract these have very strong fibers
and they are very good at contracting
which in Iran would never do or the
epithelium in our intestine so these are
cells that are made for taking up
material and they have again a very
different morphology they look very very
different and they function very
different so if they have all have the
exact same DNA and the exact same genes
how can it be that they come out in such
a very different way well that is
because I skipped over a little bit of
this expression of these genes about the
reading of these genes so I told you
that there's these promoters that then
are a signal for instructions to come
and the fact is if that promoter is
there all by itself and RNA polymerase
is allowed to bind there and do
something actually it does very very
little by itself it's not very active
there are even some proteins that can
bind in there in the region that we call
inhibitors and then switch it off
completely after data would not be
active at all
anymore but our other proteins if we
actually really want to have a gene have
the instructions being read with
proteins called transcription factors
that combine the DNA and signal to the
polymerase that this is a gene that has
to be used and they will help to
activate the polymerase to make the RNA
to make the protein and then the gene is
actually on and so different cell types
work spring will have different
transcription factors these
transcription factors therefore activate
different genes make different proteins
and make yourselves come out very
different and they don't only make a
difference between cell types they can
actually even regulate entire programs
and make entire organs an extreme
example of this that's when I first
heard it really blew my mind so I want
you to to take this well I think it's a
very striking example of this as that
people were looking in fruit flies at
transcription factors and they found a
transcription factor so one of these
proteins that is necessary for making an
eye this transcription factor is protein
is called PEC six and so it binds the
DNA and it activates some genes and
because of that the fly is able to form
it I if it doesn't have this
transcription factor the eye is not
there it's not made so eyes are very
peculiar structures we have eyes right
and if we look at the eye of a fruit fly
it actually looks nothing like our eye
if we look for our biology the diversity
in eyes is actually as extreme our eyes
the eyes of a fruit fly the eyes of a
planarian or over-over squid they look
nothing like each other and they don't
even function in the same way so our
eyes have a lens and we have a retina so
we make an image on the back of our
retina and that allows us to see and to
see pictures doing
that is exactly right yeah yeah and your
brain is able to decode that your brain
doesn't know any better so it's the
images always upside down and so it's
knows how to how to read that but it's
true so we make an image flags actually
also make an image but they have lots of
middle camera a little little eyes
animals like planarians actually don't
even make an image all they see is is
whether there's light or not they have
no way of reading where that comes from
so these are very different shapes of
eyes and very different functions of
eyes so but remarkably if we look at
this gene at PAX six that is important
for making an eye in a fly and we look
at the sequence that this that makes
this transcription factor it turns out
that that is actually conserved so if we
now look in a difficulty different model
in a mouse that doesn't have this fact
16 it also cannot make an eye and
actually it's even a known condition in
some humans where they don't make a
correct eye because they have a mutation
in pack 6 so the same transcription
factor the same protein is responsible
for the making of an eye in a wide
variety of organisms it's even a little
more crazy we can take the pack sticks
from a fly sorry from a mouse and I make
it go on somewhere else in a fly for
example in its lag and this fly will now
make an eye in its lag so it's really a
master - master regulator so the having
is one protein puts on a whole program
and it's hugely important for forming
tissues and forming structures and this
is very widely conserved and what is
actually teaches us is that all these
this variety in biology all these things
that look so different it looks like
entirely new things are actually
probably not know that's all these
things that look very different aren't
not so much new inventions but or other
variations it's more tinkering with
programs that are they're changing them
a little bit and this allows us to go
from one type of eye to a different type
of
but still the same basic principles are
underlying this and so that's the same
regulatory principles in the same
regulatory mechanisms and molecules are
used again and again and again in all
these different organisms even though
they look completely completely not like
each other and that means that we can
now actually learn from these organisms
if we want to learn how to do something
that we cannot do we can look at another
organism and ask that that is able to do
this and also how are they doing this
and well that is actually what we're
doing in my lab we're looking now at
organisms that are outside of this this
standard set and asking how can we learn
from them for example can we learn how
to live longer and healthier which is
something that I think nobody will
object to it seems like a nice idea
because we all know that's we over over
time do what we call age some of our
tissues are not functioning as well
anymore and we have a limited lifespan
we get about a hundred years and and
that's roughly the time we have but
there's organisms out there that handle
that completely differently and that's
the one that I want to introduce to you
now so this is a flatworm Schmidt AI
Mediterranean we call him he comes from
around the Mediterranean Sea and so they
live in freshwater streams and these are
actually organisms they live in many
freshwater streams if you look here in
little streams in Brooks you might find
similar flat worms around here and you
can see they can swim around they freely
swim around some of you may have seen
them on the microscope outside in the
demos they clearly have some direction
so they have eyes and you can see that
they use well swim oh it's after their
head first
they also we can see have a pharynx in
the middle of their body so they don't
have your mouth in their head they have
the mouth in the middle of their on
their belly button basically and their
mouth is also their butts of food goes
in and out they also have a lot of other
structures so they have for example
pretty big brain and they have an
intestine our gut that allows them to
digest all the kinds of things
this is the structure that I told you
about the fairings the tube that they
use to eat through and they also have
muscles all around they have structures
that help them to secrete water so to
keep homeostasis that are a little bit
like our kidneys and so there you have
all these different features so even
though they look pretty simple they
actually have a lot of the structures
that we have to but the most remarkable
thing is their ability to heal and you
firmly realize we have an ability to
heal right if you have cut your finger
if you've ever done that you know that
that's well prepared it will heal again
or if you've ever seen somebody who's
broken their arm this will actually grow
back together but and there's some other
organisms that are actually pretty good
at this it can make fins or or fishes or
things like that but for most animals if
you would chop off their heads that
would kind of be game over and I
encourage you to not try this at for
most animals this is not a good idea the
one exception I'd say it's planarian we
can chop them into pieces and they both
pieces actually just move on with their
life and this is not something
remarkably cruel we do to them I just
want to give that as a warning this is
actually something they do themselves so
when they want to multiply they actually
one of the ways they have to do that is
to adhere their kill to the surface and
crow forward and tear themselves into
two pieces so this is something they
naturally do we're just helping them a
little bit what that looks like so
here's an intact planarian and here we
have cut em into few pieces and over the
course of about 10 days each of these
pieces regenerates a full worm so it
makes a wormhole again first it just
kind of closes up the wounds and then it
starts to make this white tissue that we
call blastema so these are all newly
made cells that door makes and depending
on what is lost it will make the tissues
that are that are necessary to make a
whole worm again so if it has lost its
head like this one it will actually make
in your
you can see that it's making new eyes
making a new brain tying atom with its
body and it will be fine ever after and
the one that still has a hat now has to
make a new pharynx and making your till
and they're able to do that so you might
wonder if this is the only way they're
able to do that or whether just goes a
little further inland and you're not the
first one to wonder this actually
already around 1900s Thomas Morgan was
wondering how small can you cut a worm
and can it still regenerate so how small
can you go can you cut it in different
orientations can you cut it like that
can you cut it in little segments okay
even cut a little piece from its side
and the answer to all of those is yes so
it doesn't matter what you cut how you
cut them where you cut them as long as
there's a little bit of tissue left they
can make a worm out of it again and they
don't do it just once you can do it
again and again and again and again and
they will keep making a new worm out of
it you have a question
[Music]
[Music]
there's Morgan so they're not unique in
that sense there's more animals around
that can do this there just happened to
be not within our sets of model systems
that we picked so the little puzzle
pieces that we pick to start out with
they weren't like that but actually when
we look around there's many more that
can do this yeah absolutely so it's not
unique and that also means again that
it's not something that other organisms
cannot learn or that cannot well adjust
or try to incorporate it is something
that is universally there except the
many animals can't do it anymore have
lost the ability to do it and so the
question of course is well it's great
that they are able to do this but how
and what can we learn from this well so
the first part of the of the answer to
that is that I told you about how cells
are able to define how they go for a
cell cycle and we have a lot of cells
that are able to do that in our bodies
Canaries have even more of them they
have a lot of cells that are here
stained in in pink that are able to
divide and that also constantly divides
and constantly make new cells if we
would take those away so there's there's
things we can do never can they radiate
these animals so that they don't have
dividing cells anymore so here we can
see how many dividing cells there are in
the beginning if we radiate them they go
away really quickly and then the worms
also come to regenerate anymore so these
stem cells as we call them these
dividing cells are essential for their
ability to regenerate for them to be
able to heal and to keep living what is
quite unique about these stem cells
it's the face that they're in so I
mentioned to you that when cells go when
we make an organism we start out with
this one cell that we called a zygote
where the egg and the sperm have come
together and that divides into many many
cells and eventually makes all these
different tissues so that one cell is
able to make anything and we call that
pluripotent it means has lots of
possibilities and that is a state that
often is only during embryo
so these cells can still make anything
they want but over the course of their
development these cells become more and
more specialized so they start to shut
down some of the genes that they're not
going to need and eventually when they
are fully differentiated when they have
made a certain tissue they actually
can't go back anymore they can't go and
make something else
the planarian stem cells now actually
are still pluripotent so worse we don't
have very potent cells when we are well
born after birth
then Aryans do and they keep these cells
around all the time
so they have a large population a large
group of cells that can still make
anything and they also maintain us very
actively and dynamically so if they need
to make more more tissue so if they need
to to heal they'll make more stem cells
temporarily they'll make more of them
and then make all the different tissues
out of them and then once they're done
with that they'll go back to their
normal state on the other hand if we
give them a little bit of a radiation
and they have fewer stem cells also they
will go back to the number that they
used to have before so they'll
constantly be remaking and balancing
their stem cells kind of a unique thing
is that they also don't grow out of
control so they never make too many of
them which is something that we're also
we're very jealous of that they are able
to control these cells very carefully so
then once you have so many stem cells
how do they ever know what to make
because well that's not really the stem
cells in the Hat have to make something
different from the stem cells in the
tail and what turns out to be the case
is that actually in areas they
constantly signal to their stem cells
where they are so they're kind of radio
towers on different positions in the
animal that constantly signal you're
close to the Hat you're close to the
heads or you're in the tail and that is
what is shown here so these are ways to
visualize how these genes these signals
are expressed where these signals are
highly concentrated so you can see that
there is this signal for example here is
all in the tip of the hat so this is
signaling to the stem cells that are
receiving this signal saying you're in
the Hat you'd probably you might want to
make a brain these ones here are all the
way in the tail and so they're signaling
to the
don't make brain this is the wrong place
to do it some of them are close to the
fairings or are around the edges so the
stick the stem cells constantly listen
to these signals and thereby respond to
what is where they are and what they
probably should be making and so when we
amputate a worm and cut this off one of
the very first things these animals do
actually is make these signaling centers
again make these radio towers there it
is so this is the signaling Center for
example in the head and we can see here
a won't we have one piece that has to
make a tail and one piece it has to make
a new head when we look at the
expression that the concentration of
this signaling factor at the wound we
see that this one actually doesn't
increase it and doesn't really change
because it has to make a kill this one
one of the very first things it does is
make this signaling Center make this
radio tower again that's saying the here
should be a heads and stem cells at
around here you might want to think
about making a brain and then once they
have done that they actually fill in the
blanks in between and fill in whatever
else they need to make another thing
that we've learned from planarians is
that not only do their stem cells listen
all the time and just do what they
should be making they're also really
nice they clean up their own mess so
once the cells have divided and have
made different tissues after a while the
tissues get a litter and the tissues
don't work so well anymore and there is
a system in cells that we call apoptosis
which is a way of killing the cells off
and say we're gonna get rid of them now
planarian are very good at that they use
that not only in cells that are getting
older but also when they are
regenerating so you could imagine for
example that if we have this piece here
that has to regenerate it has now a
gigantic brain and that actually has
very little guts and it doesn't have a
pharynx so what it's doing over the
process is actually killing of a lot of
cells saying I don't need these anymore
there are too many I can use this energy
for better things and they kill these
cells off and then use the energy to
make the cells that actually need so
they're constantly
muttering how they're doing and what are
ourselves are in good shape and whether
they're still necessary and the last
thing that we're learning we're very
interested in in my lab is I told you
about how there is so much in the genome
how there are so many bases in our
genome so many letters and only some of
them are genes they're quite limited
actually there's a lot of information
that is in between that we don't really
understand very well there's also a lot
of genes in every cell that should not
be active and we can consider that's
transcriptional noise they are they
should not be expressed so a lot of
these pieces of DNA there are no genes
they shouldn't be making RNA and they
should just be quiet and be there and
that is another thing that planarian
turn out to be very very good at is that
they are constantly suppressing noise
and this is a way a system that we're
visualizing where most or actually all
of the planarian cells have active noise
suppression that is here shown in this
green staining and if the cells don't
have that anymore they're starting to
make all this kind of noise and these
cells don't function very well anymore
and this is something that is quite
unique that they are constantly
suppressing this and here we have
actively tried to disrupt it to see what
goes wrong and we find that indeed
they're making they're not functioning
as well anymore at that point so we're
using planarians as a model as a way of
learning about how to make new tissues
and how to keep these tissues healthy
forever because this is what the Aryans
are extremely good at and we're studying
all these different aspects we're asking
about these very potent cells these
cells that can make anything so what is
unique about them how is it that
planarians can keep those and weak and
how are they regulated what are the
molecules that are important for keeping
these cells in good shape and for
keeping them stable and we're also
asking about the cells that are coming
from them like how flexible are they and
how are they making all these different
tissues what does that mean to go into
all these different directions how do
they know what to do and how do they
integrate all these different signals
and so with that I want to thank the
brave people in my lab will help me to
figure all these things out
you've met several of them at the demo
and the they are also going to be around
to ask more to answer more questions so
Francine neo Seiko Michael Zeljko here
Daniel Lee and Jung Chen's also here so
they'll and here you can see a little
image of us in the lab working on all
these different questions and so it's
that I would be delighted to take any
questions that you have and give the
last image to the worms the stars of the
show
[Applause]
[Music]